auf den weg zu offenen grenzen wie lange
bleiben die strengen kontrollen noch
bestehen auf dem weg zur besserung mit
dem ebola mittel md sie wir dürfen den
europa schwer erkrankte cupid 19
patienten behandelt werden grund auf
getrennten wegen der viermalige formel 1
weltmeister vettel und ferrari haben
keine gemeinsame zukunft mehr
nachrichten nicht dass heute mit
christian sievers die welt an diesem
dienstag guten abend hinein
diese welt soll wieder ein bisschen mehr
zusammenwachsen der druck auch innerhalb
der politik wird stärker deutschlands
grenzen zu den nachbarn wieder
aufzumachen
solche forderungen kommt vor allem aus
den grenzregionen insbesondere zu
frankreich und luxemburg
gucken wir uns die aktuelle lage mal an
seit mitte märz sind die grenzen zu
deutschlands nachbarn wegen des virus
weitgehend dicht bis ende der woche
sollen die grenzen auf jeden fall noch
kontrolliert werden doch in der sache
ist bewegung mathis feldhoff ein
telefongespräch am montagabend bringt
womöglich bewegung in die debatte um die
grenzöffnung nach einem medienbericht
haben angela merkel und emanuel makro
dort vereinbart eine lösung zu finden
details sollen jetzt die innenminister
klären denn der druck auf die regierung
in berlin wächst die kontrollen
behindern familien die wirtschaft das
gesellschaftliche leben die besonders
betroffenen bundesländer wollen dass die
grenzen wieder öffnen
jetzt wo in frankreich auch lockerungen
sind
man darf dort 100 kilometer das haus
verlassen inzwischen und auch länger
wegbleiben als nur diese stunde die
bislang galt will ich dass das für die
gesamte großregion gilt nordrhein
westfalens grenzen waren immer offen
eine extra lösung für armin laschet das
müsste jetzt auch für alle anderen
bundesländer gelten ich denke dass wir
erst mal in dieser woche die
grenzschließungen beenden sollten
europa wieder herstellen sollte das
funktionieren des binnenmarkts mit
grenzüberschreitenden
gesundheitssystemen anpacken sollten
wenn es einen gewissen gleichklang gibt
und eine ähnliche epidemiologische
situation in den verschiedenen staaten
dann denke ich kann man so eine
grenzöffnung auch und rechtfertigen
trotz der forderung der
ministerpräsidenten und der empfehlung
des rk ii innenminister seehofer zögert
noch und bekommt unterstützung schon den
kompletten europäischen verkehr
freizugeben
indem wir alle grenzkontrollen
abschaffen bei gleichzeitigen
reisewarnungen bis mitte ende
die logik erschließt sich noch nicht
ganz die bisherige strikte linie bei der
auch ganze dörfer einfach getrennt
wurden läuft zum wochenende aus oder
muss verlängert werden
theo koll ist für uns in berlin
teilgenommen da liegt also einiges auf
dem schreibtisch jetzt von
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer muss
er morgen liefern
davon kann man glaube ich ausgehen die
gespräche laufen noch aber der
bundesinnenminister dürfte zur stunde an
dem vorschlag arbeiten den er morgen
früh dann dem kabinett zur beratung
vorlegen wird im kern geht es bei den
meisten planspielen höchstens um
schrittweise grenzöffnungen im
innenministerium betont man es sei
besonders wichtig dass die lage auf
beiden seiten der grenze einigermaßen
vergleichbar ist das beispielsweise mit
frankreich eben immer noch nicht der
fall ist deshalb könnte es da erst
einmal nur zu kleineren lockerungen im
grenzverkehr kommen insgesamt aber
wächst der druck auf den innenminister
in der fraktion war heute sogar mit
einem sogenannten aufstand der
randständigen gedroht worden also jener
abgeordneten die ihre wahlkreise in den
betroffenen grenzregionen haben die
kanzlerin wählte heute den mittelweg sie
warnt vor der illusion schneller
grenzöffnungen und sagt gleichzeitig
kontrollen ging aber nur bis ultimo und
ultimo wäre wohl vor dem beginn der
urlaubszeit sagt theo koll in berlin
vielen dank offene grenzen sind das eine
das andere ist eine regelung die für
alle gilt die nach einem aufenthalt im
ausland nach deutschland zurückkehren
denn dann heißt es erstmal zwei wochen
quarantäne wie lange diese pflicht noch
gilt ist je nach bundesland komplett
unterschiedlich in niedersachsen haben
die richter sie jetzt komplett gekippt
und auch sonst wachsen die zweifel
oliver deuker der niedersachse marc
oliver otto besitzt auf dem land in
südschweden ein ferienhaus so oft wie
möglich vetter dorthin doch wegen der
korona pandemie das besagt eine
niedersächsische rechtsverordnung hätte
er nach seiner rückkehr aus dem ausland
14 tage in quarantäne gewusst da ich
natürlich arbeite und auch
pflegebedürftige familienangehörige habe
hätte ich natürlich nicht einfach zwei
wochen bei mir zu hause sein können das
wäre schlicht praktisch nicht gegangen
und von rechtlichen große
schwierigkeiten sich daran nicht hält
also insofern habe ich effektiv mit der
quarantäne an hätte ich die reise nicht
machen können weil ich dann schlich zwei
wochen noch mal extra zeit hätte
einplanen müssen
otto klagte vor dem niedersächsischen
oberverwaltungsgericht und bekam recht
der senat hat festgestellt dass die
anordnung einer allgemeinen quarantäne
für alle aus dem ausland einreisenden
personen nicht von der rechtsgrundlage
des infektionsschutzgesetzes gedeckt ist
der beschluss des gerichtes ist
unanfechtbar niedersachsen will jetzt
aber nach arbeiten wir könnten
risikogebiete ausweisen wie das zu
beginn ja das robert-koch-institut zum
beispiel gemacht hat oder aber dass wir
eben über meldeverpflichtungen der
betroffenen person gegenüber den
gesundheitsämtern nochmal regelungen
schaffen der beschluss des
niedersächsischen gerichtes könnte
bundesweit folgen haben denn die
niedersächsische quarantäne regelung
beruht auf einer muster verordnung die
zwischen bundesregierung und
ministerpräsidenten abgestimmt wurde und
so im wesentlichen inhaltsgleich in fast
allen anderen bundesländern auch
erlassen wurde
das heißt in etlichen anderen
bundesländern sind diese sehr ähnlichen
quarantäne regelung ebenfalls mit sehr
hoher wahrscheinlichkeit unzulässig
reaktionen gibt es bereits aus nordrhein
westfalen und dem saarland dort wird die
14 tägige pflicht quarantäne nun
ausgesetzt
die eu-kommission will morgen ihre
empfehlungen vorlegen für ein
vorsichtiges öffnen der binnengrenzen in
europa so und dann gucken wir jetzt auf
einen weiteren komplex zum thema was ist
mit den übernachtungsmöglichkeiten hier
in deutschland auch da bewegt sich
einiges in niedersachsen zum beispiel
läuft der tourismus seit heute langsam
wieder an
mit noch großen einschränkungen und auch
bayern will jetzt einen schritt nach
vorne gehen patricia schäfer und petra
neubauer haben die details
die bayerische tourismusindustrie hatte
hohe erwartungen vor einer
pressekonferenz der bayerischen
staatsregierung hoteliers und
gastronomen hofften auf konkrete
maßgaben für die wiedereröffnung ende
mai doch es kamen nur vage ankündigungen
nichts konkretes
allerdings ein versprechen das bares
geld wert ist so so lange er im hotel
diese bedingungen einhält dort eben beim
rennen in die maske aufgesetzt wird und
so weiter kommt ja jedes zimmer belegen
wir wollen hier keine prozentuale
obergrenze einziehen und die buchungen
kommen aber die gäste zögern denn die
hoteliers können ihnen noch nicht einmal
sagen ob im wellnesshotel auch sauna und
pool geöffnet sein werden es ist für uns
ganz wichtig dass wir konkrete maßgaben
in die hand bekommen mit denen wir
arbeiten können sowohl für unsere gäste
wie für unsere mitarbeiter
denn diese unsicherheit ist eigentlich
das was das arbeiten jetzt im augenblick
am allerschwersten macht henrike ferber
will die liegen auseinander rücken die
saunen auf über 60 grad heizen und
wellness zeitfenster für die einzelnen
zimmer vergeben
außerdem hat sie die stornierung frist
verkürzt auf 3 tage vor anreise kreative
lösungsansätze auch für die küche
wirklich abstand halten keine laufwege
kreuzen feste posten für die köche es
wirklich so schaffen dass wir da keine
gefahren sehen und dementsprechend auch
die masken pflicht verzichten können
denn die wären in so einer heißen küche
auch für die mitarbeiter fast
unerträglich so könnte es gehen doch die
öffnung für touristen bleibt ein
balance-akt wirtschaftlich und
gesundheitspolitisch sucht bayern seine
position im wettbewerb mit anderen
ländern
dann schauen wir jetzt auf die aktuellen
infektionszahlen in deutschland die zahl
der täglichen neuansteckungen liegt
weiter unter 1000 im durchschnitt der
vergangenen sieben tage steckten sich
920 menschen pro tag mit dem corona
virus an
insgesamt sind stand vor einer halben
stunde mehr als 172.000 800 infektionen
durch tests bestätigt davon gelten 147
1200 als genießen
7600 67 menschen
sind in verbindung mit 19 gestorben
und alle zahlen zum stand der pandemie
hier in deutschland und weltweit finden
sie in der zdf heute unter anderem mit
einer interaktiven karte die die lage in
den einzelnen landkreisen zeigt und wo
neue beschränkungen drohen
der blick auf die zahlen bleibt
entscheidend so lange es keine impfung
gegen das virus gibt oder ein medikament
das eine schnelle und sichere heilung
verspricht immerhin gibt es da ein
hoffnungsschimmer das antivirale
medikament rem desi wir das hat in
studien zumindest die zeit bis zur
genesung verkürzt
jetzt hat die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde rem die wir für mehr
patienten freigegeben als bisher stefan
lobenstein berichtet auf diese
fläschchen richten sich die augen der
kurve patienten in kalifornien wird das
medikament hergestellt entwickelt wurde
es vom pharmariesen gilead zum einsatz
gegen ebola jedoch ohne durchbruch
zellkulturen zeigten später reaktionen
auf das corona virus weltweit wurde der
wirkstoff dann ab februar in klinischen
studien getestet unter anderem auch
gespritzt in münchen am klinikum rechts
der isar nach allem was wir bislang
wissen wir sehr gut verträglich und
lediglich milde nebenwirkungen wie
übelkeit sind berichtet worden
so kann das medikament die dauer einer
schweren infektion um etwa 30 prozent
verkürzen ist antiviral es gibt eine
schnellere erholung von fieber und
atemnot
ob sterbefälle verhindert werden dazu
sind die zahlen noch nicht belastbar
genug die usa erteilten anfang mai einen
notfall zulassung europa zieht nach will
so patienten die nicht beatmet werden
helfen auch ohne zulassung von remzi wir
an das medikament in kliniken zu kommen
bislang ist trendy sind wir nicht
ordentlich zugelassen das bedeutet es
kann nicht jedes arzneimittel verordnet
werden wir sind also darauf angewiesen
dass sein mittel in zog in einem
härtefall programmen oder klinische
studien zu beziehen
der hersteller fährt die produktion hoch
bis ende mai sollen 140.000 behandlungen
weltweit möglich sein bis oktober eine
halbe million hoffnung also aber kein
durchbruch denn rim die c4 ist kein coup
ein mittel es muss weiter geforscht
werden jetzt ins ausland die usa haben
mittlerweile mehr als 1,35 millionen
corona infizierte
das ist fast ein drittel aller
gemeldeten fälle weltweit
die zahl der toten wird mit fast 81.000
angegeben
wir haben das sehr gut unter kontrolle
sagt der us präsident für ihn sind auch
die neuesten corona fälle im weißen haus
kein problem
elmar theveßen aus washington selbst
superman trägt maske jetzt und was im
kleinen ort metropolis in illinois omas
sein soll als pflegepersonal ist jetzt
pflicht im weißen haus
masken tragen angeordnet vom präsidenten
nachdem zwei enge mitarbeiter positiv
getestet wurden der präsident trägt
keine und erklärt wer angeblich die
niedrigste todesrate in der ganzen welt
hat deutschland und die vereinigten
staaten führen die welt bei den
geretteten leben in jeder generation ist
amerika jeder herausforderung härte und
gefahr gewachsen wir auch wir haben es
gemeistert
es klingt nach mission erfüllt dabei
haben eine reihe länder niedrigere
sterberaten als die usa
sein vizepräsident dessen sprecherin das
virus hat hält nun distanz und sein
wichtigster experte warnt aus der
quarantäne vor dem kongressausschuss ihm
geht die wiedereröffnung der wirtschaft
zu schnell
es gibt ein echtes risiko dass du einen
outbreak auslöst den du dann nicht
kontrollieren kannst das könnte nicht
nur zu vermeidbaren leid und tod führen
sondern auch zu einem rückschlag für die
wirtschaftliche erholung im weißen haus
fragt eine amerikanische kollegin warum
tram statistiken wie einen globalen
wettbewerb ansieht es sterben doch
menschen menschen sterben jeden tag
überall in der welt vielleicht sollten
sich china das fragen fragen sie nicht
mich sondern china
warum sagen sie dass gerade mir
nicht gerade ihn sondern jedem der so
eine gemeine frage gestellt kurz danach
bricht der präsident die pressekonferenz
einfach ab im weißen haus wo das virus
angekommen ist ja sehr viel verwirrendes
in den usa die verwirrung wird zum teil
auch gezielt geschürt was heißt dass
emma thevis in washington folgenden die
menschen jetzt mehrheitlich noch einer
linie oder versucht mittlerweile jeder
irgendwie seinen eigenen weg zu finden
ich glaube letzteres ist franz aus und
zwar massiv es gibt zwar eine linie das
ist die leitlinie des weißen hauses vom
märz nach der bestimmte kriterien
erfüllt sein müssen dass bundesstaaten
doch tatsächlich die geschäfte und
firmen wieder öffnen dürfen
das machen viele bundesstaaten wieder
auf und die erfüllen diese kriterien
nicht die anderen bundesstaaten lassen
menschen gewähren wenn sie ihre firmen
oder ihre geschäfte wieder offen
schließen und das alles ist natürlich
kontraproduktives gibt zahlen im weißen
haus die werden geheim gehalten die
kollegen von nbc haben sie trotzdem
gestern abend veröffentlicht nach denen
von der vorletzten auf die letzte woche
in einigen ballungsräumen die
infektionsraten um 70 in manchen
ballungsräumen sogar bis zu 200 prozent
in die höhe geschnellt sind der
präsident selber sagt nein es geht
rapide nach unten mit diesen
infektionsraten das stimmt offenbar
nicht aber er selber hält sich ja nicht
einmal an die eigene vorgabe maske zu
tragen im weißen haus insofern sind das
gemischte signale die zu den genannten
ergebnissen führen und sagte elmar
theveßen in washington herzlichen dank
und aus den usa nach den usa schauen wir
jetzt auf russland das ist nach den usa
das land mit den meisten bestätigten
cola infektionen seit mehr als einer
woche sind es täglich mehr als 10.000
fälle die neu nachgewiesen werden
und da wirkt es erstmal kontraproduktiv
dass die beschränkungen des öffentlichen
lebens jetzt gelockert werden auf
baustellen und industriebetrieben geht
seit heute die arbeit wieder los
aus moskau christensen
russland macht ein bisschen auf moskaus
straßen werden wieder voll obwohl die
korona zahlen weiter in die höhe
schießen
bauarbeiter zum beispiel dürfen wieder
hand anlegen
restaurants und geschäfte aber bleiben
zu und im corona hotspot moskau gilt
eigentlich weiter eine ausgangssperre
die nicht mehr jeder akzeptieren mag ich
will raus und arbeiten gehen natürlich
haben alle die einschränkungen satt
meiner meinung nach ist die epidemie
nicht schlimmer als eine grippeepidemie
sechs wochen lang war corona stillstand
die russen sollten zu hause bleiben
präsident putin seit wochen abgeschottet
im home-office erklärte gestern die
arbeitsfreie zeit für beendet
welche maßnahmen in den regionen weiter
nötig sein sollen die gouverneure
entscheiden
der kampf gegen die pandemie ist noch
nicht vorbei
die gefahr bleibt auch in den regionen
bestehen in denen die situation relativ
sicher ist zweifel gibt es immer wieder
an den offiziellen infektionszahlen aber
232.000 infizierten gibt es in russland
offiziell nur 2100 16 tote 40 bis 60
prozent der infektionsfälle verlaufen
ohne symptome
trotz des zweiten platzes bei den
infizierten fällen hinter den usa ist
die anzahl schwer erkrankter und der
todesfälle recht geringe am nachmittag
noch diese meldung putins engster
vertrauter kreml sprecher peskow ist ein
corona erkrankt und wird behandelt den
präsidenten heißt es habe er zuletzt vor
mehr als einem monat getroffen und so
viel zum thema corona in dieser sendung
jetzt eine gute nachricht aus schwerin
ministerpräsidentin manuela schwesig spd
hat heute gesagt sie sei wieder gesund
ihre krebsbehandlung habe sie gut
überstanden und erfolgreich
abgeschlossen
jetzt stehe erst mal eine reha an und
danach regelmäßige kontrollen
es sei der schwerste kampf in ihrem
leben gewesen sagte sie
die 45 jährige hatte ihre
brustkrebserkrankung im september
öffentlich gemacht gleich zwei schwere
anschläge haben afghanistan erschüttert
dabei sind mindestens 40 menschen
getötet worden
in der hauptstadt kabul stunden
terroristen ein
krankenhaus unter den opfern sind
mehrere neugeborene mütter und
krankenschwestern die hilfsorganisation
ärzte ohne grenzen betreibt in der
klinik eine entbindungsstation rund 100
zivilisten konnte die armee in
sicherheit bringen
bislang hat sich niemand zu den
anschlägen bekannt und dann an der
niederländischen küste hat sich ein
drama abgespielt eine gruppe von surfern
war am abend bei stürmischem wind und
starker strömung in not geraten
fünf von ihnen starben die suchaktion
vor einem strand in der nähe von den
haag ist schwierig auch weil meter hohe
algen schaum die rettung erschwert warum
die fünf männer alles erfahrene sportler
in den wellen starben ist noch unklar
spekuliert wurde schon länger jetzt
steht es fest formel 1 star sebastian
vettel steigt bei ferrari aus zwischen
dem deutschen und seinem rennstall läuft
es seit geraumer zeit nicht mehr rund
viermal war vettel weltmeister mit
ferrari gelang ihm das nie hinzu kamen
querelen mit mannschaftskollege charlie
clark jetzt die vollbremsung nach sechs
gemeinsamen jahren ist ende der saison
schluss berichtet aris donzelli zweifel
an seiner position in der scuderia
ferrari waren spätestens in monza
vergangene saison offensichtlich scherle
claire neu im team seit 2009 10 hatte
entgegen der absprache vettel im
qualifying keinen windschatten geboten
die verunsicherung des deutschen zeigt
sich im rennen während die tifosi den
sieger le claire feiern
vor diesem hintergrund wird vettels
begründung für die trennung klare das
team und ich haben festgestellt dass es
keinen gemeinsamen wunsch mehr gibt nach
der saison weiter zusammenzuarbeiten
ich werde mir die zeit nehmen die ich
brauche um herauszufinden was wirklich
wichtig ist in zukunft und schon wird
spekuliert lewis hamiltons
vertragsverlängerung bei mercedes steht
noch aus mercedes-sportchef toto wolff
beteuert die loyalität zu seinen
aktuellen piloten aber die jetzt
entstandene entwicklung sagte er
lässt er nicht außer acht
auch mclaren könnte eine option werden
mit sportchef andreas seidel hat vettels
formel 1 karriere bei bmw einst begonnen
aber vielleicht ist ja auch eine formel
1 pause denkbar
so und jetzt ein doppelter superlativ
zum schluss das größte gebäude der welt
ist zur größten spendenbox der welt
geworden
das ist der burj khalifa in dubai jedes
einzelne licht amt ist symbolisch
verkauft worden um geld zu sammeln für
arme menschen in der korea-krise
mitgemacht haben spender aus 115
nationen und das ergebnis leicht für 1,2
millionen mahlzeiten und der höchste
wolkenkratzer der welt sendet jetzt
seinen dank in vielen sprachen
das nenne ich kälteeinbruch was wir da
beim wetter hatten schnee sogar in den
bergen aber damit ist jetzt schon wieder
schluss und wie es weitergeht weiß
gleich katja hornuf das heute journal um
21.45 mit der kollegin marietta slomka
wir sind morgen wieder für sie da und
zwar sehr gerne vom gesamten team
herzlichen dank etwas zu schauen und
ihnen allen einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren heute
morgen dass einige nebelfelder die
lösten sich dann aber rasch auf und dann
zogen über norddeutschland chile
schauerwolken hinweg heute nacht liegen
dann die tiefsttemperaturen zwischen 6
grad am oberrhein und -2 grad im
vogtland und direkt an den alpen und
auch an der küste felder ein bisschen
regen sonst ist es meist nur locker
bewölkt und dieser streifen mit lockerer
bewölkung der wird morgen über tag etwas
schmaler denn die regenwolken hiervon
norden die ziehen weiter erreichen am
nachmittag auch den nord hand der
nördlichen mittelgebirge und die
regenwolken von süden ziehen weiter
nordwärts
die höchsttemperaturen liegen morgen
zwischen 9 grad an den alpen und 16 grad
im rhein-main-gebiet und ganz ähnlich
geht es in den nächsten tagen weiter
dabei beschränken sich die regenfälle
doch im wesentlichen auf das
alpenvorland
es wird von tag zu tag ein bisschen
wärmer schönen abend noch